يمكن أن تجعل المنزل يبدو وكأنه منزل
أو أن مساحة صغيرة تبدو أكبر ولكن الذهاب إلى
الداخل أكثر خضرة قد يساعدك أيضًا على أن تكون أكثر
صحة وسعادة وجود نبات
يعمل معه ومشاهدته ينمو يمكن أن يكون
مفيدًا حقًا على مر السنين وقد
نظرت العديد من الدراسات في
الفوائد  من النباتات المنزلية التي تجلب
القليل من الطبيعة إلى الداخل قد يعطي
دفعة كبيرة لصحتك العقلية وليس مجرد
رؤية النباتات التي يمكن أن تساعد في تقليل
التوتر وتحسين التركيز ،
وقد أظهرت الأبحاث حقًا أن
لمس النباتات ورائحتها في الواقع يمكن أن يؤثر على
مزاجنا بطريقة إيجابية.  يقول ماثيو
فلاناجان من مركز ويكسنر الطبي بولاية أوهايو
إن الخطط قد تكون
مفيدة أيضًا لجسمك مع انخفاض
هرمونات التوتر التي تسببها مضيق الأوعية لديك
ببطء ، ويمكن حقًا أن
تنخفض ضغط الدم وتجعلك
تشعر وأن تكون أكثر صحة جسديًا
في العقد الماضي  تم الإشادة بالنباتات المنزلية المتعددة على
أنها منظفات الهواء
بما في ذلك عدة أنواع من
نباتات النخيل المطاطية dracina الإنجليزية Ivy Ficus
Boston Ferns وزنابق السلام سواء
كانت في الداخل أو في الهواء الطلق كما تعلم أن
التفاعل مع الطبيعة
مفيد حقًا لك للصحة الدقيقة
أنا آندي جاثر
أجنبي
[موسيقى]